I have a disturbing story from France
which unfortunately has become a
frequent source of news about
anti-semitism a Jewish rabbi has been
stabbed in France allegedly by a Muslim
man screaming Allah Akbar the 62 year
old victim was reportedly attacked
outside of a Brasserie in the Jewish
quarter in the northeast of Strasburg
the attacker who is understood to have
been arrested shouted the Islamic phrase
meaning god is great during the attack
according to a number of different
reports in French media the attacker was
apparently restrained by someone just
walking by until cops showed up to
arrest him the unnamed spokesman said
that the victim uh was wearing quote
clear external signs of his religion uh
and was not uh seriously injured which
is good news police are saying this is
not terrorism but a mentally ill
perpetrator with the history of mental
illness uh apparently also known to
police had a record although it was not
clear but the last time I looked what
exactly that record was for whenever we
have this conversation Louis about
mental illness and terrorism I always am
going back to it's not one or the other
necessarily there's probably an overlap
if we imagine sort of a Venn diagram and
by the way there's a whole host of
crimes where you're probably mentally
unstable to some degree and I feel like
sometimes we get mixed up in mental
illness as the as a factor in a crime
and actually being unfit to stand trial
because you fundamentally don't
understand the consequences of your
actions you don't know that if you shoot
someone they might die I feel like those
lines are very blurred often in media
reporting of mental illness in crimes
yeah uh that is true I I mean a part of
me says listen if the way your mental
illness is manifested is that you go on
uh possibly racist or uh uh religiously
tinged killing sprees uh part of me says
I don't care uh you're a terrorist and
let's deal with you like a terrorist at
the same time what if this is a person
who could take some type of medication
and no longer feel or think any of this
stuff um so then what's to blame a
health care system that has left them
behind I don't know well certainly there
plenty of crimes happening in this
country and people who are desperate and
destitute because of that uh and I see
that all the time you see that all the
time right outside this right outside
the studio uh well that's a story for
another day actually uh read what what
you we were talking about this Rachel
and when we talk about lone wolf and
actually part of some kind of organized
terrorist organization mentally ill or
not mentally ill these are pretty
amorphous designations aren't they
definitely I haven't really found a huge
distinction between the kind of the lone
wolf and perpetrator or mouthpiece of an
organization in terms of the capacity of
someone to commit a crime because I I
feel as though if you have the
appropriate plan in place in a weapon
those factors are going to matter quite
as much yeah it's made a big deal in
Jason weep the the backstory on this to
get you very quickly up to speed is that
very often we will hear oh this was Isis
inspired and then it'll find out that
there was no it we will it will be
revealed that there was no actual
connection or coordination with anyone
that was part of Isis for me that
doesn't change that the ideology
espoused by Isis may still have been a
factor i am sort of less interested
sometimes in whether someone that is
quote part of Isis directed an
individual or whether their ideology
inspired the individual it's still an
ideology that's problematic to me I
don't know how you feel yeah it's very
problem a problematic but you know at
the core of it you know terrorism in
this you know extreme hate and violence
is you know something that you know how
is house it you know how are you not
able to say that any organization that
is you know committing hate crimes you
know in inspiring this and other people
isn't part of this you know so I mean
yeah that's an interesting point which
is even if there was no operational
contact is there not some responsibility
because the I I ideology inspire them
that actually gets us Louis to the idea
of stochastic terrorism we've talked
about which is given a big enough
audience like for example Don
Trump and a big audience and suggesting
that maybe guns could be used to deal
with Hillary Clinton you will never
actually be liable for the fact that
someone may have taken your statement as
the inspiration for committing a crime
but statistically speaking given a big
enough group you might actually be
inspiring someone to take real world
action uh hard to say how that influence
is uh how it spread and and how far
reaches uh but I say who cares I mean is
it interesting to know if if there's a
quarter coordination between Isis and
some uh guy here Omar mateen let's say
uh or ultimately doesn't matter it
really doesn't I mean if it was a ratio
uh a religiously motivated crime uh it
is a hate crime and we have a system
that is set up to deal with that yes yes
but I also think that the way that
you're going to deal with the crime is
going to be different if you're looking
at a global jihad you're probably going
to put in place different measures than
if you think okay this is an isolated
person how can we deal with this one act
that they've committed yeah and it goes
to the idea of uh it actually goes back
to the hate crime enhancement thing
which we were talking about earlier in
the show which we don't need to rehash
but i'm sure i will get emails about as
far as this story is concerned